Boston's work for you here this just in
the Marine who put Jordan Neely in a
fatal choke hold on the New York City
subway is expected to be charged
tomorrow with second-degree manslaughter
he's 24 years old his name is Daniel
Penny he will surrender himself to the
NYPD in the morning Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg is bringing the
charges and here's a statement from a
spokesperson there we can confirm that
Daniel Penny will be arrested on a
charge of manslaughter in the second
degree we cannot provide any additional
information until he has been arraigned
in Manhattan Criminal Court which we
expect to take place tomorrow judge what
does all of this mean well what it means
is that when we thought the case was
being presented to a grand jury in
Manhattan that wasn't happening and
instead Alvin Bragg made the decision
for whatever reason that he would file a
felony complaint the fact that he is now
Daniel penny is charged with
manslaughter in the second degree it is
a classy felony it's Reckless homicide
uh and it has a minimum of one to three
and a maximum of uh I think five to
Fifteen if if he pleads guilty or is
found guilty now I want to be clear on
something um he's turning himself in
that means he's not being arrested I
don't understand that but but more
importantly is
um that felony complaint that apparently
is going to be used tomorrow is not
necessarily the end of the story if the
decision is made subsequent to this to
present it to a grand jury which I think
would be the smart thing to do it would
give uh Daniel Penny's attorneys the
opportunity to at least have Daniel
Penny go in and testify or to have
witnesses go on and testify if they
could find all those people who were on
the train who are making those phone
calls then the case may not end up even
being a manslaughter in the second
degree but I think this is a decision by
brag it kind of feels to me like a
political decision uh you know kind of
holding off you know the the forces out
there since he's this Progressive
liberal
um because he could very easily have put
it in the grand jury and I think that in
the end it may uh it may be resolved by
a grand jury and not by this move by
brag
would Bragg have had I guess was it
within his
powers or jurisdiction to not charge at
all sure and not take it to a grand jury
or did it oh wow okay he could have said
based upon the facts as we see him or
not we're not even going to present this
to a grand jury but is making a decision
doesn't mean that he can't then go
forward with a grand jury which I think
would be the smart thing to do I think
the public would feel more comfortable
with that and I think there would be
more of a you know of a analysis of what
happened and the respect for the process
that's what you would have done if you
were the D.A you would have done the
grand jury I would have put it in the
grand jury yeah any thoughts Jessica
um I was actually just saying this
morning to my mom we were taking the
subway that I felt like the story really
disappeared for 48 hours and I didn't
know what that meant like when it would
resurface because obviously it wasn't
going to go away forever and then this
feels like a something right they're
kind of like sucked back into the tundra
of
this incredibly complicated and sad
story and I think you know I trust the
judges opinion about a grand jury being
the best way to address this I hope that
this Marine is given the chance to
represent exactly what happened his
thought process and all of it to talk
about all the elements that we've now
seen including moving Jordan Neely into
the recovery position and that all of
those people who were involved who made
the five who called 9-1-1 I hope that
they are a part of this so that we have
the totality of the experience of what
went on on that Subway and that the
Neely family also feels like they have
been heard okay you know let me I'm
sorry let me just say one thing and and
you know the idea of the Neely family
being able to present their side you
know even before a grand jury is
important and the pro the representative
of the Neely family is the prosecutor um
that had worked in my office he is
extremely competent he is very prepared
he will do exactly what you're doing he
will turn over every stone to make sure
that they have every possible witness so
that he's represented by excellent
counsel Greg Gutfeld yeah you know this
I agree with the judge this is political
it's pro-criminal it's anti-hero it's
going to be the case of the summer or
whenever it happens we're gonna go this
is going to be a very important point
for this city this state this country
this it's time for us to get this
Progressive pro-crime ideology to walk
the plank I'm a hermit right I people
know that I don't do anything I've had
four friends of mine victims of crime
this month all right one major break-in
one a violent attack on the subway when
he was intervening right the homeless
guy was threatening people he told the
guy to knock it off and he was attacked
a couple of people I won't bring up
indecent exposure this morning uh we
might have all heard about that I had my
life threatened I don't know was that
about three weeks ago I didn't talk
about it uh these are all anecdotal
stories that are actually the Mosaic
that become statistics so you can sit
there and you can say oh my God this is
what he did he jumped you don't know how
you would react right and everybody has
to face the fact that this could happen
to them you could be in this in this
Marine's shoes and you know what those
shoes right now belong to a hero or it
could be that something like this Jesse
makes people who would be in a position
to be able to help to decide against
doing that for their own future you're
going to see a lot of strong men sit
back and watch women get attacked kids
get attacked innocent bystanders get
cold cocked on the subway sorry no one's
going to stick their neck out if that
happens this these liberal politicians
Unleashed this this criminal hurricane
onto this city
and then the one guy that steps in and
saves somebody from potential
destruction
he's held accountable but the judges the
DA's
all of these stupid politicians that
allowed this guy to roam free and punch
four people in the face two of them on
the subway
he's now in trouble how do you know this
guy wasn't about to knock some woman's
teeth out
you don't he's done it before he would
have done it again judge will we hear
from him in the morning
uh I I you know what I imagine you'll
hear from his lawyer and you know I want
to say one thing I believe in this
system I'm still a Believer after all
the disappointments that we see every
day and discuss every day I'm still a
Believer and you know what Jesse the guy
who sits there and just watches a woman
get attacked I think Kyle Rittenhouse
and I say to myself you know what juries
are not stupid they know we're living in
a time when we don't have the protection
we need and we're forced to act so there
may be a positive end to it that could
be a Wisconsin jury but this is a New
York City jury it could be different
yeah all right thank you we will keep
following the breaking news we'll bring
you any updates hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else